it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies and for that we turn to
author of the forthcoming book the thief
who stole heaven
hitting bookstores next week fox news
contributor raymond arroyo
all right raymond the white house press
secretary
is taking questions in a new way
well each week laura jensaca uses
official white house social media organs
to respond to the probing questions
citizens want
answered oh not the border crisis or the
administration's plan to turn your
elections upside down no
no the important stuff it's tonight's
marquee malarkey
bunch of milwaukee
what did you have for breakfast this
morning i love breakfast
i would eat breakfast for every meal if
that was an option what is president
biden doing to create unity
in our country this is what the
president ran on
and what he's focused on every day it's
about his actions every day
his rhetoric and how we all speak from
this
government the unifying rhetoric of
president biden and how they speak from
this government law
we saw so many examples of that this
week for instance
this unifying moment when he reacted to
governor abbott
opening up texas the last thing we need
is neanderthal thinking that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask forget it
then there was this unifying racial
moment
it's amazing indian of dissent
americans are taking over the country
you my vice president my speechwriter
when i i tell you what
why is he so racially obsessed
accomplished people
are taking over the country their race
is secondary but biden seems stuck
in his old ways laura you cannot go to
a 7-eleven or a dunkin donuts
unless you have a slight indian accent
you're really going to the greatest hits
there royal the old ones
at the old biden but every time someone
does something a governor or mayor
that is not in line with the medical
cartel where we're going to stay locked
down and
quadruple mass forever they have to they
have to dismiss them and defame them and
demean them
that's all they know how to do because
the science actually is not on their
side and the way they're handling this
well if he were a children's illustrator
he would have been cancelled by now for
these comments but
all of this is distractions laura the
dogs the valentines the press secretary
they the the marquee malarkey is meant
to keep us from this reality
joe biden is not really in charge this
was from
thursday watch now am i supposed to
speak or is swathi going to say
something i was told i was going to
hear from swansea did you want to say
something i'll be quiet
um this this is his default position
i'll be quiet what do i do
who's speaking where do i go huh what
and then the curtain comes down normally
it's very sad to watch i have to say
well
he he looks like many of our relatives
when they were getting in their later
years and
look we all might be we all might be
there soon sooner than we'd like but
it's not it's not reassuring ensuring
that's all no it's not
and laura look turning to another topic
nobody likes getting
shots or vaccines and look there's
nothing worse than a doctor or nurse who
prolongs what i call
the shot suspense you know they make a
big production they put on the glove
then they have to swab you like they're
priming a wall then they have to tap
tap the skin they soften it up knead it
just get the shot in and get it over
with
so it was nice to see dolly parton in
addition to singing
during her vaccination she dealt with
this drama far
better than i would have do what you got
to do you're the doctor
i'm just the patient i didn't know he's
going to be so clumsy
i hope you're going to do better
well it didn't take this long to film
nine to five
i'm still waiting
laura for a second there i thought she
was going to sing her hit
i want to slug you
but she didn't do that she restrained
herself and look this woman gave them a
million dollars at vanderbilt for
research into covet
and she's doing a psa for them the least
they can do is speed up the action you
know i mean don't make her wait
raymond raymond she could have cooked an
entire breakfast for six people of grits
eggs bacon and fresh squeezed juice
before they finish that vaccine
that is the worst they really they
always have trouble getting the needle
in my arm like my
i don't know the blood never comes out
or whatever so they're always doing this
and then don't you love it when the
phlebotomist
tries to go in and get the blood and
they're like oh this one's not working
we got to go with a butterfly
what then they go in the top they're
like oh we have to go in near the wrist
it hurts a little more
the back of the hand like oh my god i'll
give you the back of the hand
yeah well look let's give dolly big
points for restraint there i
i was amazed by her her grace under fire
before we go laura
nancy pelosi introduced joe biden the
other day
at a zoom event with democrat lawmakers
and she used her grandchildren
my grandchildren have for many many
years
been long time friends of joe biden i
took them for candy
at a place dylan's in new york well they
have sort of like swinging doors
i hear them pronounce
in order to open these doors we do not
say
open sesame we say open
biden that's our magic word
open fighting i love it
look for one one pauses
when considering what you just said this
could be the watch word for the entire
party at this point
anything they want they just say open
biden and he signs the paper and
off it goes but after hearing this i
think most viewers will want to say
close nancy have a good weekend laura
raymond it's like it's the same thing
with dr fauci may i remember it was
mother may i remember that game mother
may i take three steps mother may i
he's like dr fauci may i go see my
mother who i haven't seen in here mother
may i travel
to oregon mother man dr fouchy man
that's the new kids game although at
some point it will be cancelled so
i have to just we'll see just a warning
to everybody it will be canceled raymond
great to see you have a wonderful
weekend great to see you and okay